All right, let's make sure the stream is
up.
All right, it looks like we're live.
Good.
Welcome to Thursday.
So, today we're going to be continuing
our discussion of Dynamo. Uh I was just
reminded a student stopped into office
hours to
ask some questions about the Dynamo
paper and I was just reminded of there's
really so much in this paper that we
aren't going to have time to cover.
Because this paper kind of has the
kitchen sink of distributed systems
ideas.
And there's a lot in there that we
honestly don't have time for. Um
we're trying to hit the big themes, but
there's a lot of detail. So,
you know,
don't think of what we're talking about
in class as as comprehensive. However,
today we're going to try to talk about
one of those big ideas
uh that's in this paper that is not
specific to Dynamo. They weren't the
people who invented it.
Uh
but it's one of the ideas that they they
really used to good effect.
Uh so, first I'm going to we're going to
talk about
sharding,
also known as data partitioning.
And then we're going to talk about the
concept of consistent hashing,
which is uh
which is used in Dynamo, but not unique
to Dynamo. It's one of the ideas that
comes up in this paper, but they didn't
invent it.
Um
I realized last time that uh
I didn't talk about um some of the
systems that have been inspired by
Dynamo. I guess I briefly mentioned
Cassandra when I was talking about uh
quorum systems, but um
but Dynamo is, you know, it's not open
source, of course, but um but it has
inspired some great open source work.
So, one of the systems in particular
uh that was inspired by Dynamo is the
Riak database.
So, Riak uh
has some interesting history. Um
it was it was developed by a company
called Basho,
and um
in the
kind of mid 2010s,
uh
Basho was um
uh kind of
at the forefront of distributed systems
in industry, and they had a great blog,
they ran great events, and I met some
great people who were working for them.
And that's
sort of how I entered into the
distributed systems community was these
folks at Basho um
uh who worked on Riak.
Riak is an open source clone of Dynamo.
And one of the things that they did, I'm
not actually not sure if this is still
in the Riak documentation, but at the
time
they had a really interesting
section in their documentation where
they compared Riak with Dynamo by going
section by section through the Dynamo
paper
and talking about how
their product uh
implemented every aspect of the paper.
Um
so,
I'm checking actually looking at their
documentation right now to see um
if that's still the case. I'm not sure
if it is. In any case,
uh you can go look it up um Riak on your
own um if you're interested. All the
documentation is still online.
And um
uh
it's a cool system to check out if
you're interested in a in a
uh open source
implementation of something that's a
whole lot like Dynamo.
They also have some pretty good um
kind of practitioner-oriented
explanations of the concepts in their
documentation.
Something to check out.
All right. So, let's just jump in with
um
with today's topic.
So, we've spent a lot of time talking
about replication, right?
And as you know, replication is involves
having multiple copies of the same data
on different nodes. So, in the systems
that we've talked about so far,
every replica stores all the data.
So,
that involves something like
you might have some different machines.
So, if it's key-value store,
let's say that you have some key-value
pairs.
Something like this.
And you've got a bunch of clients
who may be talking to one or more of
these machines, right?
So, everybody stores all the data in the
replication uh approaches that we've
talked about so far. Sometimes this is
called full replication.
Do you see any problems with doing it
this way?
So, we've been talking all this time
about how a replication is good.
And now I guess I'm asking you to think
about
what might not be good about having
everybody store all of the data.
Any thoughts on that?
Right, good points. So,
storage cost for sure.
If you have to store all the data on one
machine, then that machine needs to have
a lot of storage, right?
And that costs money.
And yep, it sounds like a couple of
people
said exactly the same thing in chat. And
then there's the then there's the cost
of keeping the copies consistent, right?
So, if you are storing the data
everywhere, then every time any of these
machines gets updated, then that update
needs to get broadcast to all of them as
you're finding
working on the assignments. So,
I can think of a couple of issues with
this approach. Um
What if you have more data than fits on
one machine?
That's one problem.
Then keeping them all consistent is
another issue.
If everyone stores the data,
consistency is arguably
more expensive to maintain.
Okay.
So, there's some problems with doing it
this way.
And furthermore,
what if it's primary backup? So, what if
it's a primary backup type approach?
Maybe this one here, maybe M1 is the
primary.
So, if you have lots of clients making
lots and lots of requests,
the primary has to do a lot of work,
right? It has to field all those
requests.
And the clients can't just talk to the
other two machines because in that
situation you would lose strong
consistency.
Well,
what if you did this instead?
Let's talk about pros and cons of
something that looks like this.
Now you've split up your data set across
three machines,
and they don't have to be kept
consistent with each other because
they're all storing totally disjoint
parts of the data set.
So, that's kind of nice, right? It means
that if if this client only needs X,
then they can just talk to that machine.
If this client only needs Z, then they
can just talk to that machine and so on.
So, in in this kind of a situation,
we've saved the effort of keeping these
consistent and we've distributed the
load.
So, that's kind of nice. But, what's
wrong with this?
What did I lose in going from that
earlier design to this design?
Okay, some servers might not re- receive
a request.
Yeah, okay. But, what's the bigger
issue? What did I lose
between going from this approach
that we had before to this one up here?
Exactly, fault tolerance. Yeah, our data
isn't replicated anymore.
We lost replication, so now we don't
have fault tolerance. Okay.
So, let's put it back.
I'll give these different names.
I'll call this M11, M21, and M31 and
let's do some other machines across
here.
So, I've split up the data now
among multiple nodes. I've also put back
the replication.
So,
right now I'm doing both replication and
sharding.
So, splitting up the data set among
multiple nodes is is known as sharding.
And I've got three shards here.
So, we could call this shard one,
this shard two,
and this one shard three.
And then we could think of these
as being our replicas.
So, sharding and and replication are
orthogonal to each other.
You can do sharding without the
replication. That's kind of what we had
a minute ago uh when we just had
something like this.
Or we can put the replication back in.
And now we have both sharding and
replication.
So, splitting up the data set among
multiple nodes like this
is not to be confused with network
partitions.
Uh network partitions, as we talked
about, are something that you don't
want. This is also called partitioning,
but this is partitioning on purpose.
Not to be confused with something that
you don't do on purpose, which is a
network partition.
Okay, so what are the reasons for doing
this? Well,
one reason, of course, is so that you
can store more data that can fit on one
node. In a hypothetical situation where
we could only store one key-value pair
on on a node,
um then you'd have to do this, right? If
you wanted to store more than one.
Now, in this particular example, I
happen to have split up my data set into
three partitions. Um in practice, we
would have a whole bunch of key-value
pairs on every partition, but a disjoint
set of them on each. So, this is just an
illustration, right? In practice, you
would you would have many, many
key-value pairs per partition, but there
would be a disjoint set on each.
So,
storing more data than can fit on one
node is one reason to do this.
Or capacity, to put it
uh
more concisely.
So, increased capacity.
And then another reason would be
increased throughput.
So, these clients now,
if they are happening to talk to
different parts of the data set, then
they both can both do so at once and
those nodes don't have to coordinate
with one another. So, throughput means
more throughput means you can serve more
requests in a given amount of time.
So,
just to give you an idea of other
possibilities,
you could also imagine a different sort
of partitioning setup.
And I don't want to confuse you too much
um because this some something like this
works, right? But, you can also imagine
something something different
where you have your data partitioned,
but in this case there's um
it every node here corresponds to a
particular every node belongs to one
shard, right? But, you can imagine a
different sort of setup. So, for
example, we could have this.
You could imagine having
say three machines.
And let's say that I do it this way.
So, I could put
X
on M1 and M2.
I could put Y
on M1
and M3.
And I could put Z
on M2 and M3.
So, this is also sharding.
And then here's our clients over here.
So, this is kind of nice
because
I've managed to split up the request
load, right?
So, if one person is is um uh
making a request and they need X, right?
They have a choice of who to talk to,
right? But, they maybe they can talk to
this machine here.
Maybe somebody else needs Z, so they can
talk to one of these machines over here.
Uh so, we can still get some throughput
that's better than if we were not doing
sharding.
But, something kind of interesting is
going on here. So, we have two copies of
every um
uh
of of every key-value pair.
So,
you can imagine a sort of setup where
every machine is going to be acting like
a primary for one part of the data set
and is a backup for another.
So, maybe this right here
is the primary
copy of X and then this is the backup
copy of X.
Maybe this is the primary copy of Z
and this is the backup copy of Z.
And maybe this is the primary copy of Y
and this is the backup copy of Y.
So, in that kind of a scenario, if you
need X, you would talk to machine one
because machine one has the primary copy
of X. Then those updates would have to
be synchronized with the backup copy,
which is over here.
So, those machines would talk.
Likewise, if you need Z, then you would
talk only to machine two.
And then you would have to synchronize
here.
And so on.
So, this is an approach where there's
more than one
shard
per node.
And this is also a totally reasonable
way to do sharding.
So, sharding is really important. It's
really important in real world systems.
It gives you better throughput, right?
Because you can serve different parts of
your data set from different machines at
the same time.
And it makes it possible to store a data
set that's too big for anyone node. So
increased capacity, increased
throughput.
If you were not using a strongly
consistent replication strategy, then
you were already able to serve requests
from different machines at the same
time. Dynamo does this, for instance.
But you definitely still need
partitioning if you want to serve these
bigger than can fit on one node data
sets.
So real systems are going to do both
replication and partitioning.
And
as you can kind of see from coming back
to this picture,
uh the choice of the partitioning
strategy is mostly orthogonal to the
choice of the replication strategy. So
in our discussion today,
we're going to mostly forget about
replication and focus on partitioning.
In other words, we're just going to be
looking at this piece of the picture.
So it's not that replication doesn't
matter anymore.
It's just that we're going to be
focusing on this piece of the picture,
and you can assume that the data is
replicated somehow.
So how it's replicated is not going to
be our concern for the moment. Instead,
for the moment, we're just going to be
concentrating on how do you split up
your data set among the shards?
So we're going to leave aside
replication for a little while and focus
just on sharding for a while.
So let's um let's get rid of the
replicas from our from our picture and
just focus on partitions.
And if it makes you nervous to see data
only appearing in one place, then you
can imagine that this is getting
replicated somehow. But just imagine
that that conversation is going to be
orthogonal to what we're talking about
here. And everything that we're going to
be talking about here is something that
can take place
in the presence of replication.
Okay.
So let's say that we have a large amount
of data, and we want to partition it.
How do we decide which data to put on
which nodes?
How do we decide how to split up our
data among the shards? Or how do we
decide to shard our data?
Let's keep it simple
and continue to imagine that the data is
these key-value pairs. So it's a simple
data model.
So
which key-value pairs go where?
Well,
what are we trying to accomplish with
our partitioning strategy? What do you
think we want to aim for?
Or another way to put that is what makes
a sharding strategy good?
What do you think?
Good. Yeah.
So
you want to avoid hot spots, right?
You'd like to get things reasonably
equally distributed or reasonably evenly
distributed among the the nodes, right?
So okay. How would you accomplish that?
Well,
one possibility is
you could try randomly assigning
records to nodes.
What would happen if you did this? Well,
if you have a you know,
assuming that you're that that you have
a way to to uniformly random assign the
data to the node to the nodes, then this
will be pretty good at evenly spreading
the data around.
So this checks that check mark.
But what might not be good about
randomly assigning the data?
So just to give you a hint about where
I'm going,
there's one good thing and then what not
so good thing about this approach. So
what do you think the not so good thing
about randomly assigning the data might
be?
What if you're a client?
What if you're a client and you want to
know where Y is?
Exactly. You won't know where to look
for the data again later.
So randomly assigning will do really
great in terms of evenly distributing
the data, but it'll also make it hard to
find what we want later on.
Okay.
Kind of the opposite of this would be if
you just decide to put everything on one
partition, right?
So then it's easy to find what you want.
It's trivial, right?
I guess I'll use the same
check marks uh
approach that I used before.
Easy to find what we want.
But it's
absolutely the worst you can possibly do
in terms of um
uh in in terms of even distribution.
Okay.
So those are kind of two straw man
strategies that uh
that won't work.
What can we do instead?
Well, let me throw another slightly
better strategy at you, and tell me what
you think about this.
You could have every partition store a
particular range of the keys.
Partition by key range.
So for instance, if my keys are
alphabetical strings,
then you know, I could say that M1 is
responsible for a certain range of the
alphabet, and M2 is responsible for a
certain range, and M3 is responsible for
a certain range. So
you know, maybe maybe M1 is responsible
for like keys A through H.
And um maybe we have like
B here.
Maybe M2 is responsible for
I through R.
And we've got P here.
And M3 gets us through Z.
Maybe we have um
Y here.
Okay.
So
this seems to work okay, and some
systems do something like this.
But what's the downside of doing it this
way?
Well, finding what we need is not a
problem in this case.
You know, if the client knows where to
look, then
it's not hard to find what you need.
But
what's the problem?
Any ideas why this might not be great?
Yeah, so the the point made in chat is
some ranges might have more keys than
other. What if the data starts coming
in?
What if the rights start coming in and
they're all like, you know,
S
Y
Z
So, you'd end up with an uneven
distribution of data,
right? Because your keys
weren't uniformly distributed across the
space of of
of um of the alphabet, right? So, then
that means your data is now unevenly
distributed across the servers.
So,
distribution of data might not be great.
So, key range partitioning probably
isn't a good way to go
unless you have some way of knowing in
advance that your requests are going to
be
adding a uniform distribution of keys.
But,
there's hope.
We can actually solve this problem very
easily.
How do you take data that's not
uniformly distributed and make it
uniformly distributed? Who knows? Who
knows the answer?
Good. Great suggestion. Suggestion is
hashing
the keys.
So,
a hash function
is a way to take data that's not
uniformly distributed and make it
uniformly distributed. So, a good hash
function could take our possibly wildly
uneven distribution of keys
and will distribute them evenly across
its output space. So, let's take a look
at what that might look like.
So,
let's take a
hash function.
Let's say MD5, for example.
So, MD5 takes an input
and produces an output.
So, maybe the input is a string.
Let's say that this is a picture of the
input space of MD5.
So, let's say that we have a bunch of
strings from like
uh up here to
Z down here.
And then we've got a bunch of other
strings in here.
And so on.
What does the output space look like?
Well,
with MD5 we get outputs that are
somewhere in the range from zero
to
2 to the 128
- 1.
So, the hope,
if we have a good hash function like
MD5, is that
even if your strings are,
you know,
unevenly spaced across this input space.
Like let's say that you have a bunch
clustered here at the top. Let's say
that you have like
apple,
awkward,
and so on.
So, not not really a nicely distributed
set of strings.
The hope is that these are all going to
map onto more or less
even
points
somewhere in the output space.
So, this is great, right? Because
it'll give us a way to distribute the
keys evenly across the nodes.
The trick is just that you have to hash
them.
Then you give every node some evenly
sized piece of the output space.
So, how would you do that? Well, if we
had our three nodes um
M1, M2, and M3 that we talked about
before,
then one way to do this
is take the output of the hash function
and if you need to split this data over
say these three nodes,
uh do mod three of the hashed value.
So, in other words, if something landed
here at zero,
then that would go onto machine one.
If it landed at one, that would go onto
machine two.
If it landed at two, that would go onto
machine three.
And so on.
So, you would end up splitting up the
data hopefully more or less evenly. So,
you know, maybe in this approach
I have no idea what the MD5 hash of
these strings are. Um but maybe
hopefully you would end up with
something more or less even. Like maybe
this would end up here.
Maybe this would end up here.
Maybe apple would end up here as well.
And maybe
So, maybe you'd get something like this.
It's not necessarily perfect, but the
more data that you have, the more likely
it's going to be that it's evenly spread
out over this output space. And so, even
though it's a little bit uneven at this
point, the hope is that you would end up
with something that was more or less
evenly distributed.
Furthermore, it's not going to be hard
to figure out where things are because
this is a really easy function to
compute.
So, the client, when they need to look
up a particular key, like if they need
to look up this key, for example,
they can just take the hash of it and
then they know which machine is going to
store uh
and and and they're going to rather
they're going to take the hash of it, in
this case hash mod three, and that will
tell them where to look for that data.
So,
if I want to know where to put a
key-value pair, you know, whose key is
apple,
then
first I hash it to get this 128-bit hash
value.
And then I do mod three of that, and
that'll give me, you know, some machine
ID.
So, the output here is going to be In
this case, it's going to be zero, one,
or two, and that'll tell me one of these
three machines.
And if I want to look up a key and I
need to know where to find it,
I just do the same thing. I calculate
that key's hash, which is an easy, quick
computation, and then I do mod three or
mod N for whatever number
of nodes I have.
And that can be done either on the
client side or it can be done uh on the
data store side.
So, that all sounds great.
So,
partitioning
by hash of key
mod N
where N is the number of partitions.
Okay.
Seems pretty good.
Unfortunately, there's a catch.
You knew there was going to be a catch.
What's the catch with this approach?
Yeah, a partition can get full, yeah.
But, I think you have that that issue
with any approach, right?
So, if a partition is starting to get
full,
but however that that question kind of
points to
the issue. So,
what what happens if your if a partition
is starting to get full? What should you
do then?
What if you start to notice that machine
three is getting pretty full? What would
you do?
Yeah, okay, key collision. So, the the
the the worry is that different inputs
could hash to the same thing, but I
don't think that's too big of an issue.
The output space of MD5 is pretty big.
It would be fairly unlikely.
Um and even if it did happen, it
wouldn't be the end of the world, right?
Um
So, I'm I'm not I'm not really too
worried about that.
Great. Yeah, it's the question I just
asked was what do you do when a when a
partition starts to get too big and
somebody correctly said in chat, "Well,
you could add a node." But then the
hashes won't be correct. Yeah. Yeah.
What happens if I try to add another
machine? What happens if
a partition is getting full or more than
one partition is getting full? Maybe
they're all getting full. And so, I try
to add another machine.
Oh, no.
Now what? The trouble with doing this
hash of key mod n thing is that if n
changes,
now most of the data has to hash to
somewhere else, right? Most of the data
or it doesn't hash to somewhere else,
but gets mod n to somewhere else, right?
Most of the data has to move around.
So, let's say that n changes from three
to four, like that. So, we had three
machines and now we have four.
Let's say before we were doing, you
know, MD5
of
aardvark
uh and we got one, right? And let's say
that that put us on M2.
Say these are indexed from from zero.
Or I should say MD5 of aardvark mod
three.
Maybe that gave us one before.
Now let's say I do MD5 of aardvark
mod four.
Uh
and now let's say that I get three. So,
now that key,
which I already stored, now needs to
move from this machine to this machine.
So, our our
So, that seems kind of messed up, right?
You know, actually, let me let me give a
different example. Let's say it changed
from one to two.
This is what seems messed up to me.
We've added a new machine
and now I'm saying that aardvark has to
move from here to here.
That seems kind of messed up, doesn't
it? Because
if you add a new machine,
then it would make sense if you have to
move things onto the new machine, right?
But
now I'm saying that because we've added
a new machine, now I have to move
something from an old machine to another
old machine?
Instead of moving data to the new
machine, I've just shifted around the
data on the old machines. And that could
that might have to happen with all of
these. Maybe some of them would move to
the new machine, sure. But maybe some of
them would have to move from one of the
old machines to the other old machine.
So, that seems bad, right? We really
don't want to have to do that.
So, the drawback here
too much data movement
when n changes.
In an ideal world, we would do the
minimum amount of data movement
necessary.
So, that raises another question. What
is the minimum amount of data movement
necessary if we want the data to be
evenly split among the nodes?
So, let's say that we have
six keys like this. We have yeah, one,
two, three, four, five, six.
Um so, we have six keys
on three nodes. It's about two per node.
Maybe they weren't perfectly evenly
distributed before, but you know, let's
let's suppose that they're more or less
evenly distributed. So, before we had
six keys on three nodes, about two per
node.
And say that we add one more node, like
this. Say that we add M4. So, now
there's six keys and four nodes.
So, if we have six keys and four nodes,
um
how many keys per node do we have now on
average?
Or should we have?
All right, let's think about it. Well,
four nodes, six keys.
If you had the same number on each,
right? Then well, six
divided by four is 1.5, right? So, you
can't have one and a half, but uh it
would have to be either one or two. So,
we'd hope for either one or two
on every one of the four nodes.
So,
on average, right?
You would want to move about that many
to this new node. You'd want to move
about 1.5 keys to this new node, you
know, one or two. Let's say one.
So, that's the minimum movement possible
to achieve an even split.
So, to write this out,
let's say that we had something like
this.
So, we have our strings like
And this might not exactly match the the
sharding that I had before,
but that's okay.
Okay, so those are our three nodes.
Let's say that we add one node to the
system.
So, here's our brand new
sparkling new node
with no data on it yet.
We want to move the minimum amount of
data to it
uh to be rebalanced, right? So, because
we now have six keys
and four nodes,
uh
we want to have about
1.5 keys per node.
Okay.
So, that means we should move one or two
keys here.
So, you know, let's say that we move
this one.
That's about as good as a split as any
other. So, that's the minimum movement
possible to achieve an even split. So,
that was this particular example where
we had six keys and and four nodes, but
in general,
if you have k keys and n nodes,
then that number k divided by n
is the minimum movement possible
to get an even split.
So, we ought to be looking
for approaches that let us get that
minimum possible movement
at the point when n changes.
We accomplish this using something
called consistent hashing.
Gives us this minimum movement.
So, there's a lot of terminology overlap
in distributed systems, unfortunately.
So, we're We're this word consistent yet
again.
We've already used this word in the
context of
of consistency models.
And now we're using it to mean something
entirely different. I'm sorry to say,
this is just an unfortunate terminology
overlap in the distributed systems
literature.
It's a different concept. So this has to
do
with how you shard data
and and how you move data
when the number of nodes that you're
sharding over changes.
So consistent hashing is an approach to
sharding
that will give you this really nice
property. Unlike what we saw before
where you are partitioning by the hash
of a key and taking mod n,
uh consistent hashing gives us this this
nice
minimum data movement.
So let's pause right here and
do our quiz.
And then when we come back we'll talk
about how consistent hashing works.
Right, so I will see you at 4:21.
Yes, that's right. I have a document
camera. So the document camera is
pointed at the paper and my laptop
camera is pointed at me.
It's um I can I can share a link.
It's
the brand is IPEVO.
It's the IPEVO VZUR.
And I like it a lot.
Um
Let me Let me find a link and share it.
No, it's not very big. It fits pretty
nicely on the desk here. It's it's
intended for
home use.
I don't remember where I got it.
It could have been from Amazon.
I P E V O
Yeah, I just put a link on Zulip here.
It's a really nice thing.
Yeah, it plugs in via USB. So
it plugs into my laptop and uh
the USB powers it and also sends data.
So
um yeah, it works pretty nicely. It's
also got a light.
Um
didn't have the light on before. I
should have had the light on. So it
it's got a light built in and
um it's got some kind of cool settings
maybe I can show off later.
Mhm.
Yeah, I love this thing. It's easy to
use.
I do go through a lot of paper though.
Yeah, I was thinking about getting You
can get like a
uh
sort of a like a like a a
wipe and rewrite
notebook, a wipe book
uh which I was thinking about getting.
Uh
but if I'm back in the physical
classroom in fall then maybe I won't
bother.
Yeah.
No, it's not very expensive. It's a um
uh what is it about like
200? Yeah.
Okay.
Right, 2-minute warning.
Oh, with the two cameras? Yeah, so I'm
I'm
uh
presume I'm I'm just using uh my laptop
camera and then I'm sharing my screen
and I have So, I don't have it plugged
into Zoom as a camera. I'm using the
software that comes with the Doc Cam,
which is called Visualizer,
uh which puts up whatever is the current
uh
whatever the camera is currently
showing.
And then I have I'm tabbing between that
and a browser window here.
It's um
Yeah, I mean, I'd be happy to uh
to meet with you if you're interested in
a little demo.
Okay, it's 4:21, so let's resume.
Okay. So, let's talk about consistent
hashing and how that works.
And once again, consistent hashing is
rather confusingly named.
I didn't pick the names of these things.
Okay.
So, the idea with consistent hashing
is that we can think of all of our nodes
as being arranged in a ring.
And you might recall this uh from the
Dynamo paper.
And the points around this ring
are going to correspond to the output
space of our hash function.
So, let's say that we have our nodes
like this. So, let's say that this is
M1,
M2,
M3,
M4.
And so, if this is zero up here,
maybe this is one,
and so on around the ring,
and then coming if if we're again saying
that our hash function is is MD5,
it's got a 128-bit
output, right? So, this would be like
all the way to
all the way to this a very large number.
So,
that's what we would have if we were
using MD5, but that's too big a number
to think about, so let's pick something
a little bit more manageable,
um
like
two to the six,
uh which is 64.
So, the ring will go from zero to um
two to the six minus one,
uh which is 63. I'll just write 63. That
might be a little easier to think about.
Um so, maybe this is like 16 right here.
Maybe this here is 32.
And this is 48.
And every node is going to correspond to
a particular point on the ring. So,
maybe M1 is at eight.
And maybe M2 is at 20.
M3 I have at 32.
And maybe M4 is at 47.
So, each of our nodes is going to belong
to a particular point on the ring.
I don't really care what point.
Um and you know, how do you decide which
point it belongs to? Well,
maybe you could hash the name of the
node using our hash function or hash the
IP address of the node.
And if you do that, then the nodes will
be more or less evenly spaced around the
ring. At least you hope so.
Okay, so now let's some let's say
somebody wants to store some data. We've
got all these nodes. It's time to start
using our key-value store. So, let's say
that I want to store um
uh a key. Let's say that the key is
apple. Or let's say that I want to write
to the key apple.
I'll just worry about the key um right
now and not the value.
Uh so, how do I figure out which of
these nodes to put it on?
Well,
I'll hash it just like before. So, I'll
take the hash
of that key,
uh and I'll get something that's in the
output space of the hash function. Um
so, let's say that it's 14.
We look at point 14 on the ring. There's
not a node there.
So, what we do is we walk around the
ring clockwise until we hit the first
node. In this case, it's M2.
So, the key apple
and its value
are going to get stored there.
So, a key is going to belong on
whichever server is the successor
of the point that that key hashes to.
This means if somebody wants to look up
a key,
same deal. You hash the key, you get a
number.
You walk around the circle. So, here you
would go to 14, let's say.
You walk around the circle until you hit
a node, and that's the place that you'll
find the key that you wanted.
And the circle wraps around.
So,
let's say that I hash the key artwork,
for instance.
And let's say that that one um
let's say that that hashes to 62.
So, where will that key be stored?
That's right. Yep, it'll go on M1.
So,
in Dynamo,
they use consistent hashing in this way,
but they also use the this ring to
decide where to replicate things.
Uh so, let's say everything has to be
replicated three times, for example.
Then, the way that they do it is for any
key,
it's going to have some node that is its
home,
which is whatever node that it hashes to
using this approach of um
computing the hash of the key, finding a
point on the ring, and then walking
around clockwise until you hit the first
node. So, this node M2 is going to be
the home node of this key apple.
So,
if every key had to be replicated three
times, then you're going to store it
there,
but you also store it at the node after
that,
and the node after that.
And then aardvark, this would be its
home node, so it would go there.
And here.
I can spell aardvark.
So, we're using the ring both uh
to to figure out where to put things in
the first place in terms of sharding,
and we're also using the ring to
determine where to replicate things. So,
in in Dynamo, uh they will replicate uh
a key along with its value, right? So,
I've left the values uh that these these
keys map to out of the picture.
But, values are there, too. Like, the
value of apple might be something. The
out value of aardvark might be
something, and so on.
Um
but the way that it works in in Dynamo
is that you store something at its home
node, and then if the replication factor
is three, then you also store it at the
node after that, and the node after
that, until you've stored it in three
places.
So, it's slightly more complicated than
that uh in Dynamo because
the paper calls it a preference list.
So, every node has what's called a
preference list,
which is the list of places where that
node's data should be replicated to.
And interestingly, that the replication
if it the the preference list is
actually going to be longer than, say,
three if three were the replication
factor.
Does anybody remember why the preference
list has to be longer?
That's right. Yeah, some replicas could
be down, so or unavailable for whatever
reason, unreachable. So,
they still try to replicate in three
places
uh even if one of the nodes where
they're supposed to be replicating is
down, and they just keep going down the
preference list until they find three
nodes that are actually up.
Okay, so why did we start talking about
consistent hashing? Well, we started
talking about it in the first place
because we wanted to solve this issue
of data movement, right? We were trying
to get a some approach that would give
us the minimum movement when we added or
removed any nodes.
And we wanted to make sure that we moved
around as little data as necessary. And
that magic number that I gave before,
which was K over N, which is the number
of keys divided by the number of nodes,
we figured out that that was the minimum
movement that you would have to do to
get an even split
uh when you add a new node.
So, how does consistent hashing actually
solve that?
Well, let's add a new node to our ring.
Let's say that our nodes are getting
pretty full. Maybe maybe we're looking
at our at what we have, and we're
looking at the data, and things are like
maybe I don't know, 80% full. So, we're
starting to think, okay, well, we better
better add another node.
So,
let's call it M5.
And let's say that it goes uh
right here.
Let's say that it hashes to this
position 60 right here.
Now that we've added this new node,
which keys
do we have to move?
What do you think?
Yeah, okay. So,
I guess in this particular picture it
might be none of them. But, let's say in
general. So,
let me say for instance that
the string zzz
let's say that its hash value was um
I don't know, 50.
So, let's say that it hashed in right
there.
So, what would have happened before M5
was present? Well,
the string zzz hash hashes to 50, and
then we would have had to walk around
the ring until we hit a node. So, what
would have happened before is that
everything that hashed to anything in
this whole
range
would have landed on M1.
That's what have happened before M M5
entered the picture.
Now that M5 has entered the picture,
though, now the range that M1 is
responsible for is smaller. So, now um
M5 is now only responsible for this
s-
or sorry, M1 is only responsible for
this smaller range.
And M5 is going to be responsible for
this.
So, anything that would have hashed to
um
to M1 because it fell in this space here
between uh M5 and and M4, anything that
would have been on M1
now ought to be moved over to M5.
So, a chunk of the data that's on M1 now
needs to go over here when M uh
when M5 gets added to the ring.
But, on average,
it's only going to be
about this much data that needs to move.
On average, we'll only have to move K
over N keys over, where K is the total
number of keys that are stored
in this new system, and N is the number
is the new number of nodes.
And the really great thing about it is
these nodes
aren't affected at all.
So, they don't have to do anything
different. They can be, in fact, totally
oblivious to all of this that's going
on.
So, M4 doesn't have to care. M3 doesn't
have to care. M2 doesn't have to care.
Now, maybe sooner or later M4 should
update its preference list, maybe to add
M5 and so forth, that kind of thing.
Maybe some of the other ones have to
update their preference list, too,
depending on the replication factor and
that kind of thing.
But, they don't have to move any data,
which is really great.
So, that's nice.
Okay, what about if a node crashes?
Suppose M2 goes away.
Suppose it crashes.
Who's going to be affected by M2
crashing?
Well, what was M2 responsible for?
Well, it was responsible for this range,
right?
Remember how we talked about how Apple
uh had a the hash of Apple was 14, and
so we walked around the ring and then
stored Apple here at M2.
So, now anything that hashed to a spot
on the ring that was in this whole range
here would have been stored on M2.
So,
that's what, 9 through 20?
The 9 through 20 range of the hash of
the hash function. So, now
M2 is gone.
So, now
M2's neighbor, M3, is going to have to
take those keys on.
Right? So, M3 here has to take on some
more keys. M3 is now responsible for
this
big
chunk of the ring.
So, this used to be M2's,
and this part just here used to be M3's.
Now M3 is responsible for a bigger chunk
of the ring.
However, now M4 and M5 and M1 are
unaffected by that.
So, it's business as usual for these
nodes over here.
Meanwhile, M3 has to has to take on the
data that that um
a-
that was uh
that M2 can no longer store. But, this
actually works really nicely because in
Dynamo in particular, remember how we
said these keys are being stored on a
node that's their their home node, but
they're also being replicated onto its
successors around the ring. Well,
if this node crashes,
and its successor node has to take over
its key range, well, hopefully it has
the backup already.
So, now it can just say, okay, these
keys are mine. I'm I'm the home of these
keys now. These keys live here now. I'm
their home now.
And of course, at this point, you know,
whoever's operating this system will
probably want to bring another node up
to replace that um that lost node.
Um but, until they do, this neighbor
node is going to be picking up the
slack.
And that's consistent hashing.
Questions about this?
Uh so, the question is
is the home
for these now M3, and would they need to
be propagated to the next nodes? Yeah,
so, one thing that you might do at this
point, um if M2 has crashed,
uh M3 can hopefully figure out that M2
has crashed. Maybe M3 is is um is
constantly trying to gossip with all of
its neighbors, right? So, if M3 finds
that it can't talk to M2,
um
now M3 decides, "Okay, I'll be the home
for those now."
Uh
and I'll start my own
preference list for replicating those.
And so then,
maybe its preference list has many
nodes, right? Maybe like we said more
than three because it has to be careful
of the fact that some of those might be
down. So,
it's going to try to talk to this one
and this one, you know, maybe this one
over here didn't have Apple yet. So,
maybe it will try to replicate to that
one.
On the other hand, maybe M2 was only
intermittently down. So, maybe it'll
come back.
And then it'll say, "Okay, I'll take
over this chunk
of the of the ring again."
Can you think of any ways that
consistent hashing might go wrong?
Let's use our last bit of time to talk
about that.
How could this go wrong? What could go
badly?
Mhm. Cascading crashes because of
increased load.
So, you're imagining a scenario where
like a node dies and then its neighbor
has to
take on the load that it was carrying.
And then because of increased load, it
dies. Yeah, okay. Yeah, so there had
better be a system administrator who's
keeping an eye on this ring, right?
If they're starting to see a lot of
crashes, then they'd better start
working on bringing up some nodes,
right?
There's definitely some human
involvement here.
It's somebody's job to monitor this
system and
try to maintain a
a global view of what's going on that
these machines lack.
Keeping us all employed, right?
Okay, what else?
What else could go wrong?
Sure, yeah. Like if a couple of nodes
crash,
then
their neighbor has to take on that huge
range, right?
So,
yeah, it could happen.
Something you have to watch out for.
That's a little bit related to thing I
was going to talk about, which is
what if the nodes aren't actually evenly
spaced around the ring?
So, in this picture I have them fairly
evenly spaced, right? Especially um now
that I had an M5 to the picture.
But,
you could imagine a scenario in which
the nodes aren't evenly spaced.
So, we know that a good
hash function is going to map its inputs
over its output range as evenly as
possible. So, that's what makes a hash
function
uh that's one of the things that makes a
hash function good, right? We're hoping
that even if the
inputs are
uh
clustered up in particular parts of the
input space, we're hoping that they're
going to be mapped uh
in a in a hopefully fairly even
way in the output space. However,
if you have not that many inputs,
then you can't necessarily expect that
output space to be evenly covered,
right? The more inputs that there are,
the more likely that it is that you'll
get an even distribution.
So, these key-value pairs, you know,
presumably you have a whole lot of
key-value pairs. If you didn't have a
whole lot of key-value pairs, you
probably wouldn't be building a
distributed system.
But, um and you certainly wouldn't be
sharding. But, uh
so hopefully the key-value pairs are are
more or less evenly distributed over the
output space. But, but what about the
these machines? What about these machine
identifiers or whatever it is that
you're using to hash them to points on
the ring?
There aren't that many of those. In this
picture I only had five.
So, you can't necessarily expect that
output space to be evenly covered.
The more inputs that there are, the more
likely it is that you'll get an even
distribution though. So, here's a trick
that you can play.
You can actually have every one of these
every one of these machines
be hashed to many points on the ring.
So, a node could pretend to be multiple
nodes.
So, a node could pretend to be say four
nodes or 30 nodes or 80 nodes.
And every one would have its own
identifier,
which would then get hashed to some
position on the ring.
And that would make an even distribution
more likely.
So, there's still only one machine, M1,
but
we're pretending
that that M1 gets hashed to a whole
bunch of different points on the ring.
So, I'll use a different color.
So, here's like a a fake M1.
Here's another fake M1.
Here's another one.
And similarly for all of the other ones.
This will make it more likely that we've
evenly distributed the nodes around the
ring.
These,
however many fake machines that we have
here,
are called virtual nodes.
So, what's the purpose of virtual nodes?
Well,
they make it so that you're more likely
to have an even distribution of nodes
around the ring.
And
that's nice because
if you don't have an even distribution
of nodes around the ring, then assuming
that your key values that your keys are
getting more or less evenly hashed
around the ring,
then some nodes are going to end up with
a lot more than others.
So, you want to make it more likely that
your nodes are evenly distributed around
the ring, too. And virtual nodes help
with that by just having there be more
nodes.
Now, these are all actually one machine.
But,
they're thought to be at different
points on on the ring so that here,
if I were to um
if I were to let's say that this M1
right here were at I don't know, 24,
um
if I were to have
um a key,
say foo,
uh that hashes to right here. So, say it
hashes to 23,
then I would walk around the ring to get
to 24. And then it would then this key
would actually get stored on machine
one.
Of course, with this setup here where I
have a bunch of M1s and only one each of
the others, then that wouldn't be good.
But, the idea is that you would have
virtual nodes set up for all of your
machines. So,
you would be
spreading the nodes out over the space
around the ring in a way that would
hopefully avoid huge gaps.
So, virtual nodes are nice because they
improve the distribution of nodes on the
ring.
And there's actually another reason I
can think of why they're nice. And this
is something that's mentioned in the the
Dynamo paper.
Does anybody know what else uh what else
is nice about virtual nodes?
Well, let's say that you have one of
these machines. Let's say it's
M1.
And let's say that it has a like a a 10
terabyte drive.
And let's say that you have M2
um
and it only has a four
terabyte drive.
What can you do about that?
At that point you don't want
the same number of keys to be stored on
M M2 as M1, do you? Because then
you'll run out of storage space on M2
more quickly.
It turns out virtual nodes can help with
this. So,
if you're using virtual nodes, then you
can give different numbers of virtual
nodes to these machines. So,
maybe this machine with the 4 TB drive
uh
only has 20 virtual nodes.
And then this one with the 10 TB drive
has 50 virtual nodes. So, the machines
that have more capacity
can then be responsible for some larger
slice of the space of keys.
So, those
uh 20 virtual nodes that map onto M2
would then be scattered around the ring
somehow. Those 50 virtual nodes that
that correspond to M1 would be scattered
around the ring somehow. And then,
assuming that that keys are more or less
evenly distributed around the ring, then
hopefully you would get about the right
amount of data corresponding to the
storage capacity on those machines. So,
virtual nodes can let you
have different numbers of virtual nodes
per physical node.
So, you can account for differences in
storage capacity.
So, that's kind of cool.
All right.
In the few minutes that we have left, do
you see any downside to this this idea
of using virtual nodes?
I can think of one thing that
you can maybe think of as a bug or maybe
think of as a feature.
So, one downside is that if you're using
virtual node, let's say that M1 goes
down. Let's say the physical M1 goes
down. Well, then
before it was kind of easy to think
about what happened. If a node crashed,
then its neighbor has to take over
for its part of the key range. So, it's
pretty straightforward.
But,
if M1 goes down and you're using virtual
nodes,
then all the virtual nodes are going to
be down, too. So, now there's lots of
little places around the ring that are
going to be affected.
If a If a If a physical node that's
represented by many of these virtual
nodes crashes, then lots of separate
little areas on the ring are going to be
affected.
And they're all going to have their own
neighbors, right? And then so lots of
other nodes might have to step up to be
responsible for those parts of the ring.
So, in the Dynamo paper, they actually
call this a feature. They say, "If a
node dies, then rather than just having
its immediate neighbor take it on, then
the load is spread out." So, this sort
of answers the one of the questions that
we were talking about earlier, right?
When we were saying, "Wouldn't it be
terrible if nodes right next to each
other on the ring crashed and then then
this whole space ends up having to go on
to the the immediately neighboring
physical node?" Well, if you're using
virtual nodes, then things are a little
bit different. Then everybody can help
kind of step in and pick up some of the
um
some of the work.
So, in the Dynamo paper, they say this
is good, right? It's good to have this
load spread out. Um and I can see why
that would make sense.
The only thing I don't like about this
is that it's a little bit less simple
and obvious what's supposed to happen if
a node dies, and you don't get the the
nice situation we had before where the
other nodes could just kind of go on,
you know, doing their thing uh
obliviously. But, we still have this
nice property that that there's there's
still there's still this minimal data
movement. It's just that the data
movement happens between more of the
machines.
And then, the only other downside I can
think of of virtual nodes is that
replication might get a little more
complicated, right? Because you want to
make sure not to replicate to two
virtual nodes that are actually the same
physical node. So, you have to think a
little bit harder about who to replicate
to.
Cuz that wouldn't give you any fault
tolerance, right? If you replicated to
two virtual nodes, but they're actually
the same machine, then if that one
machine crashes, then you lose both
copies.
So, that's what virtual nodes are.
And implementations of this kind of
thing in practice typically do use
virtual nodes. And this is discussed in
a little bit more detail in the Dynamo
paper if you're interested in taking a
look. The questions of like how many
virtual nodes you need, these are tuning
questions that you might answer on, you
know, based on the the characteristics
of your system.
All right. In the 1 minute left, I want
to remind you all that Bang Bang Con is
happening.
So, I've talked about this before, but
Bang Bang Con is the conference that
some friends and I run. It's happening
right now. In fact, our next session is
starting in 5 minutes.
So, and you can go to
bangbangcon.com/livestream
to watch the talks. It's free.
And I hope that some of you will take
the time to check it out. I know that a
couple of you already have, which is
awesome. So,
if you have an hour and you want to hear
some cool talks about the joy,
excitement, and surprise of computing,
go take a look.
Otherwise, I'll see you next week. Enjoy
your weekend.